please I want a simple a task force of
the most dangerous people on the planet
they're bad guys worst of the worst
[Music]
was this cheerleading tryouts
hi boys
Deadshot ships before he's a crocodile
he eats people burns people you're
possessed by witch she's just crazy I
should kill everyone in escape sorry
the voices I'm kidding what they really
said this is the deal something gets
killed save the world I can't wait to
show you my toys
[Music]
you
seriously the hell's wrong with you
people
you're bad guys it's what we do
[Music]
hey youtubers its charlie happy DC week
so here we go new Suicide Squad footage
let's break it down so if you guys
aren't familiar with the songs they're
playing over this trailer it's Bohemian
Rhapsody
you probably recognize it from Wayne's
World but really the biggest thing about
this trailer is explaining who each of
the characters are in the in what I
think is probably the best parts of it
are where it has little origin story
moments like you see the Joker getting
dumped in a vat of toxic waste
previously I thought this was a Harley
Quinn origin story but it looks like
each of the characters will have moments
like that especially in Chandra Syme
really excited about that always been a
big cara delevingne fan I think the
reason that they went with Bohemian
Rhapsody like as you start seeing
moments with all these characters or
just to highlight how unpredictable they
are like the tempo of the song changes
it goes from being this really sweet
classical music to this head-banging
rock music so it's kind of a barometer
for how each of these characters
vacillate between being super calm and
just being batshit crazy Harley Quinn
reading a Harlequin romance novel nice
Deadshot
definitely a man that lives by a code I
don't think that they changed the
character that much for Will Smith I
think they expanded the part a little
bit when he signed on this shot is a
really big character but usually you see
like with big movies like this when they
cast an actor that they really want
they'll enhance their part so like
Killer Croc here really awesome
character probably not as big in the
movie as Deadshot just because it's Will
Smith Diablo firestarter Captain
Boomerang Amanda Waller just as crazy
and deceitful as any of the rest of them
she just hides a little bit better when
they say this movie is all about the
difference between being bad and being
evil
she's much closer to evil like on the
spectrum of bad
she's definitely just as bad as the
worst people inside the Suicide Squad
really digging the new color logo
these troops looks like they're rolling
in to haul them to Amanda Waller like
we're gonna carry you off you have this
opportunity take it and we will commute
your sentence Killer Croc Hannibal
Lector nice Captain Boomerang get in the
bag treatment sounds like a lot of fun
as you can see Harley Quinn always loves
to perform for a crowd rick flagg
and what looks like enchantress when she
is not enchantress like she doesn't have
the makeup on but I love this look here
it just implies that something terrible
happens to her of all the terrible
people in Suicide Squad I would say Rick
Flagg is the closest to being legit
but they cast Joel Kinnaman so I'm
guessing he's gonna have a little bit
more of an edge in this
movie enchantress with her powers
activated they definitely had a lot of
CG to this that's why it looks so much
more shiny than the previous trailers
this looks like flak right after he
gives them Amanda Waller's offer rolling
into battle the rumor is is that the
reason the Suicide Squad is assembled is
because of this huge threat that the
Joker is behind and the Joker's one
person obviously he doesn't do
everything by himself he works with
other people when it suits him so
there's probably gonna be a bunch of
people The Suicide Squad will fight like
they're all not just gonna gang up on
Joker but the Joker is usually the man
behind it all speak of the devil and he
shall appear get a better look and some
dialogue from Jared Leto wearing the
classic bowtie that's a deep cut some of
this looks like his flashbacks Joker
Lamborghini nice enchantress in the
White House that looks like a lot of fun
The Joker looking a little OCD but quite
the artist this actually reminds me of a
scene from Game of Thrones with a bunch
of dead bodies made to look like this
katana soul blade I love that they're
actually doing the real soul blade too
it actually steals people's souls when
she kills them now on the TV show they
haven't really done that with the TV
version of katana but the funny thing is
is I just posted an arrow trailer for
the second half of arrow season this
year and katana was in it so you'll see
katana on TV before you'll see her in
the movies again arming up grab a little
drink between bombs katana ingesting a
soul this actually looks like early
Harley Quinn before she joined the
Suicide Squad we're awesome titles
really hard to tell who this is this
could be an Vil there are a couple
people in the movie that haven't been
revealed yet they're just like a cup a
couple of minor characters a couple big
ones I think that they haven't revealed
yet I know this kind of looks like
kryptonite we'll just have to wait to
see you can let me know what you think
it is in the comments below like who
this person is it looks like their
crystals growing off of them but it
could just be a regular metahuman more
Killer Croc Harley Quinn pre
transformation all hell breaks loose
Deadshot versus Joker's army Suicide
Squad roll out so this is actually
follow-up from a last scene this makes
me think it's something even crazier
this could be something based on the
crazy stuff that Lex is doing I
definitely feel like there's some
Kryptonian stuff going on here pre
enchantress and chant rest's Diablo
lighten it up and will looks like the
Joker taking Harley Quinn through the
same transformation that he went through
the toxic waste try not to drink any of
that this kind of feels like the final
act of the film so like whatever
craziness is going on these all
like different green lantern colors
colors of the emotional spectrum would
that not be crazy if this had some green
lantern Easter eggs in it you got some
yellow you got green yeah blue you have
purple tell me this does not look like
something from Green Lantern in BAM so
let me know what you guys think of the
trailer it feels like there's some
really crazy stuff that they haven't
told us about yet some otherworldly
Justice League related things
now the Joker is gonna be one of the big
antagonists of the film it seems like
there's something even bigger going on
like this Kryptonian thing in the subway
that looks like it blows up into this
really big looking thing so let me know
what you guys think and remember this
movie isn't coming out to the fall so
we're gonna start with Batman vs
Superman there might be some kind of
post-credit scene that tees up Justice
League and Suicide Squad so I'm
expecting to see a couple more trailers
whenever Batman vs Superman comes out
speaking of which congratulations to
this week's reverse flash ring giveaway
winner Ronald akin be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
and there is a new route like I'm
starting a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'm gonna be doing a Wonder Woman
video next for the footage they showed
off and then I'll do my flash episode so
they're gonna be a couple more giveaways
just because there's so much DC stuff
happening this week so while you guys
wait for that stuff to post you can
click here for all my other Suicide
Squad Batman V Superman videos and you
can click here for my last flash video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you